dr mark siegel is in focus now fox news
contributor and professor of medicine at
nyu langone medical dr siegel you and i
have been together since the very
beginning of this pandemic
calling balls and stripes call this
one harris i don't like how political
this is and you just heard about it from
mark meredith it's it's all this
worrying about governors at the heart of
this it's a medical story it's not a
legal story and it's not a political
story what's the medical story the
medical story is that the vaccine
protects you from severe disease and to
some extent protects others from it
spreading to you but here's the problem
and here's why that new york post op-ed
is correct
in the way this was framed by the
president it's almost as if he's saying
that vaccinated unvaccinated people are
lepers watch out for them they're going
to infect you it's leaving out the fact
that if you are vaccinated harris you're
almost definitely no matter who you come
in contact with are not going to end up
in the hospital are not going to end up
dying are not going to get severe
disease so calling it a pandemic of the
unvaccinated isn't accurate because
vaccines protect you and it's it's plain
to people's neuroses uh oh here comes an
unvaccinated person here comes a leper
there's got to be a better way to do
that also when it comes to large
businesses i'm a little disappointed in
using the bully pulpit for that too
because i would think that large
businesses would come to this conclusion
on their own and many have saying you
know we don't want our employees to be
unvaccinated we're going to offer that
option where you could test out but we
really want to try to get everybody
vaccinated to protect our business so
our business doesn't have to close so
that it doesn't we don't lose our whole
workforce so i think it's a private
sector issue and i don't think governors
should be involved i don't think the
president should be involved i don't
think governors should be involved we
have to get more people vaccinated but i
don't know that we need to do it by
shaming people well look
last i checked joe biden has never been
a doctor nor will he be one i would
imagine he'd have to get on that if
that's the case but when he says he's
running out of patience imagine how
small businesses and the rest of america
feel about the pandemic whether you're
vaccinated or not we're all running out
of patience because we do want freedom
we want freedom from the virus i don't
know how he could get that one word
freedom wrong
not only is president biden imposing
personal medical decisions on the public
he's also dr siegel telling parents how
to parent their own children
for any parent
it doesn't matter how low the risk of
any illness or accident is when it comes
to your child or grandchild
trust me i know
so
let me speak to you directly the safest
thing for your child 12 and older
is to get them vaccinated
they get vaccinated for a lot of things
that's it get them vaccinated
trust me
he says dr siegel
definitely the one that's out there
telling people to get vaccinated i also
didn't like when the president talked
down to primary care doctors in the
united states like me and urged us to
have a conversation with our patients
are you kidding me we've been doing that
for months and months and months and we
don't need to hear it from a politician
or even a president we've been doing it
we go over it with our patients what are
your concerns why are you reluctant and
i don't necessarily think it's always
political the way the president is
saying plenty as you know harris you and
i have talked about this plenty of
minority groups are afraid to get
vaccinated because they've never trusted
the medical establishment and certainly
not the government on health care issues
so the president is putting it all into
one group like it's all republicans not
the case and and he doesn't need to talk
down to doctors or to parents or
children and one more thing the way to
address the school issue he was very
light on this he needs to get it so that
kids can test at home before they go to
school we need free
rapid testing in every household so that
children can be tested before they go to
school that will keep schools open look
and when we travel with our corporation
fox you can you get a little kit and you
can do this at home it's not difficult
it's very quick you you send it out if
you need to depending on the type of
test it is you get quick results but you
can do it right there in your kitchen
dr siegel real quickly because there's
been a lot of talk about joe biden not
mandating things for his own staff at
the white house
yeah
that's very concerning too you know
that's the kind of hypocrisy and
changing messages all the time that
doesn't work of course the white house
needs to be a place where everybody's
vaccinated and everybody's wearing masks
you can't get up there at a podium and
criticize other people unless you're
going to do it yourself and one more
thing on this by the way it's not one
size fits all harris i want all health
care workers vaccinated i want everybody
that's in contact with other people that
could spread it vaccinated but it's not
like every single person in the united
states puts the pr presents the same
risk and there was no differentiation
made and to your point start with your
own house
there you go dr siegel thank you for
again uh joining me in focus to figure
out some stuff that we've heard from
those who want us to do what they say
all the time without asking any
questions good to see you thank you hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now